[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing what the Wizarding
World was up to while Muggles fought
against each other during World War II
while there's lots of evidence who
suggested witches and wizards take part
in many muggle events without us even
noticing their participation in a large
number of global conflicts and events
like World War II remain somewhat of a
mystery even to this day unlike Wars
such as the American Revolution in which
we have documented proof that certain
Wizarding communities chose to
participate in the conflict While others
decided to abstain there's no real
evidence to support whether or not
witches and wizards took part in World
War II using the American Revolution as
an example the following is an excerpt
from wizardingworld.com showcasing such
proof which explains exactly what
happened during the magical Congress of
the United States of America otherwise
known as macusa's debate of a magical
American and British involvement in the
revolution in what is now known as
Washington President Elizabeth
McGillicuddy presided over the infamous
country or kind debate of 1777.
thousands of witches and wizards from
All Over America descended upon makusa
to attend this extraordinary meeting for
which the great meeting chamber had to
be magically enlarged the issue for
discussion was did the magical community
of their highest allegiance to the
country in which they had made their
homes or to the global underground
Wizarding Community were they morally
obliged to join American no matches in
their fight for Liberation from the
British Muggles or was this simply put
not their fight the arguments for and
against intervention were protracted and
the fight became vicious
pro-interventionists argued that they
might be able to save lives
anti-interventionists that Wizards
risked their own security by revealing
themselves ourselves in battle
Messengers were sent to the ministry of
magic in London and to ask whether they
intended to fight a forward message
returned sitting this one out
mcgilliguddy's famous response was even
shorter mind you do while officially the
American witches and wizards did not
engage in battle unofficially there were
many instances of intervention to
protect no match neighbors and The
Wizarding Community celebrated
Independence Day along with the rest of
American society although not
necessarily alongside them in addition
to the Wizarding world's debate
regarding the American Revolution we
also have indications of witches and
wizards involvement in the Great War of
1914-1918 which of course went on to
become known as World War One much of
what we know about this first global war
and The Wizarding communities
participation in it comes from the
Fantastic Beast movie franchise for
example muggle or no match if your State
sign Jacob Kowalski and famed magic
zoologist newt's Commander had the
following Exchange in 1926 eight years
after World War one had ended you fought
in the War of course I fought in the
wall everyone fought in the War you
didn't fight in the war I worked mostly
with Dragons Ukrainian nine bellies
Eastern front and Newt wasn't the only
scamander to participate in the Great
War Theseus Commander newt's older
brother was a noted war hero during the
events of the first world war this is
proven when someone mistakes nude for
his older brother upon his arrival in
New York City in 1926 they interviewed
Theseus Commander the war hero the fact
that witches and Roses participated in
World War one is also accepted as Canon
on wizardingworld.com in which readers
can find the following passage the
Wizards of America had played their part
in the Great War of
1914-1918. even if the overwhelming
majority of their Nomads compatriots
were ignorant of their contribution as
there were magical factions on both
sides their efforts were not decisive
but they won many victories in
preventing additional loss of life and
in defeating their magical enemies
evidently by contrast in the United
Kingdom British Minister for magic
Archer evermond passed an emergency
legislation for bidding witches and
wizards to get involved in the Great War
due to his fear that it would reveal the
Wizarding World to a multitude of Mughal
communities thus committing mass
infractions of the international statute
of secrecy despite the law however it's
said that thousands of witches and
wizards in Britain to find everman's
wishes and helped where possible which
is supported by what we know of both new
to and Theseus commander and their
involvements with the Great War
this of course brings us to the second
world war and the question of when World
War II began what did the global
Wizarding communities do once again
similar to World War One much of what we
know about magical society's involvement
in the second world war comes from
Fantastic Beasts in fact we first get a
glimpse of World War II through the land
of the Wizarding World in Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of Grindelwald set in
1927 it is during this film The gallic
Grindelwald reveals the atrocities that
will be committed by Michael kind in
just a little over a decade during World
War II Grindelwald is able to do so by
using his abilities as a Seer to show
scenes from some of the most terrible
and tragic parts of the war including
the Blitzkrieg the Warsaw Uprising the
Holocaust and the deployment of the
atomic bomb of course despite these
muggle atrocities is grindelwald's way
of attempting to recruit more acolyte
followers to his cause of overpowering
non-magical humans for the greater good
in the case of Quinny Goldstein and many
others this tactic works wonderfully the
next Fantastic Beasts film which takes
place in 1937 just two years before the
start of the second world war then shows
his Grindelwald getting ready for battle
of his own within the Wizarding World
here he attempts to rise to power
through the international Confederation
of wizards a Wizarding intergovernmental
organization similar to the United
Nations of mughals by rigging the
election with a dead Chillin a mythical
creature used to assess and select the
organization's leaders these
circumstances which feature
grindelwald's persuasive oratory
abilities as well as his efforts to
build an army of like-minded people to
overpower those he sees as less than
seem to indicate that grindelwald's war
is one that will greatly parallel the
events of World War II in Gaelic
Grindelwald we have a leader who
believes in a supreme race and who
excels at giving performative speeches
as to why his political beliefs warrant
a global conflict
sounds an awful lot like one Adolf
Hitler if you ask me not to mention the
fact that we already know that Albus
Dumbledore is finally able to confront
and defeat Grindelwald in an Infamous
duel in 1945. the same year that World
War II ends to me this indicates as a
few fans of the franchise have also
suggested that perhaps the next
Fantastic Beasts will reveal an alliance
between the dark wizard Gaelic
Grindelwald and Nazi Germany with this
in mind I think it's highly likely that
Muggles and witches and wizards fought
side by side during this global conflict
as we've gone over earlier in today's
video The Wizarding World was often
advised to remain impartial and not get
involved in muggle Wars however this war
may have actually also been their war
that is if Grindelwald did in fact lend
power to Hitler in the Axis powers of
countries like Nazi Germany and the
Empire of Japan then it would make sense
for the witches and wizards who opposed
gullard to fight alongside the Allied
countries which of course included the
United Kingdom and the United States
furthering this theory is the fact that
it's said that Leonard Spencer Moon the
minister for magic during this time
enjoyed a good working relationship with
Winston Churchill while that in itself
doesn't explicitly prove that British
witches and wizards were overtly
involved in the second world war it does
rather suggest it since Churchill was
the British prime minister credited with
leading Britain to victory in World War
II it has also been confirmed as Canon
that grindelwald's War and World War II
fed off each other throughout their
duration meaning that the two were
related if not intrinsically intertwined
with one another in any case during
World War II I believed that the
Wizarding World was involved in conflict
and battle where the witches and wizards
were exclusively fighting Gaelic
Grindelwald and his acolytes or they
were engaged in Warfare with Grindelwald
and the ax's powers remains to be seen
what seems rather obvious to me though
is that they weren't simply doing
nothing if they weren't helping out
their muggle compatriots it likely
wasn't because they didn't want to get
involved but rather they were quite
occupied fighting a war of Their Own
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think do you
agree with my theory please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live